good morning it's Wednesday it is
morning but it's once again night
morning as you can see Oh look Jupiter
alright ank it is nearly dawn in Roscoe
New York readers of the book will likely
know from the setting that it's a pretty
serious day so I don't think I'm gonna
be messing around too much with
Matondkar today instead let's talk about
the project for awesome so a project for
awesome so so so Hank the project for
awesome
so like the project for awesome is a
huge that's NAT Wolff who plays a cue in
the movie and John Lennon who weighs
Margo Roth Spiegelman right so the
project Rossum is an annual charity
event in which the nerdfighter community
tries to decrease worldsuck and increase
world also had the project for awesome
will be on December 12 and 13 when's
your birthday seventeen now after the
project Rossum usually is but we have to
move it because it's the end of the
paper town
yeah we gotta focus on that birthday
that day I thought this change might be
better received if it came from you know
like NAT and car oh this is just got so
weird I'm having such an unpleasant
experience so we're moving the project
for awesome to December 12th mostly
because of the paper town shoot but also
because of Nats birthday I'm sorry about
that but I really want to be part of it
but we also want to talk to
nerdfighteria about maybe doing a few
other things differently beginning with
comments so the project for awesome
started out in 2007 with youtubers
making videos about like charity instead
of you know cats on Roombas or whatever
this was back when people discovered
YouTube videos primarily unlike the most
discussed page or the top-rated page
nerdfighteria came together to
essentially hijack YouTube's algorithm
and that was amazing back when those
pages existed but then YouTube made
comments progressively less important to
discovery basically comments spamming
just doesn't work
I don't know where to vlog from so I
think I'm gonna go to this creepy
abandoned building so the other
challenge that we have is that
traditionally a hundred percent of
project for awesome money goes to
charities chosen by nerdfighteria at
projectforawesome.com so this is a great
system but two things first it's hard to
get like matching money from wealthy
private donors and second because we're
always so busy comments spamming I think
that sometimes there isn't enough
attention paid to the actual like voting
for charities so here is my proposal in
nerdfighteria I want your feedback about
there's any new ideas you might have the
first day of the project for awesome we
raise money for three organizations that
are known to be excellent and efficient
when it comes to combating global
poverty and disease this will allow us
to get a lot of matching donations like
potentially hundreds of thousands of
dollars and also to decrease a known
cause of world suck and then the second
day the project for awesome will be all
about raising money for charities chosen
by nerdfighteria and instead of comments
spamming will have like meaningful
discussions in comments of project for
awesome videos
so to summarize hank here is my proposal
December 12th and 13th instead of
December 17th and 18th on December 12th
at noon Eastern everyone who wants to
upload a video about a charity of their
choice members of the nerdfighter
community try to watch as many of those
videos as possible have substantive
discussions and comments and then all of
nerdfighteria votes carefully and
thoughtfully for their favorite
charities at project for awesome calm
all of the money raised after the first
day of the project for awesome will go
to those charities all of the money
raised on the first day will go to
charities that are well regarded in the
field of global health and poverty and I
can't decide if I should go in the store
I kind of want to it's quite lovely
we've experimented a lot with the format
and scope of the project for awesome
over the years but one thing has never
changed it is my favorite time of year
to be a nerdfighter and I can promise
you this year the perks are going to be
amazing I'm gonna go back to the movie
set I will see you this is the last time
I get to say this it's kind of a bummer
tomorrow